action quake was one of the greatest  mods of all time there was a split what  was going to become of the action quake  community and it was action half-life  and Counter Strike  before Jeff Goodman goose Arizona  working on overwatch he and actually and  I were actually in a team fortress plan  we didn't even like no II didn't even  know each other  maybe sometimes I look back to Titan and  where we got a little we got a little  squirrely under the weight of this giant  idea we were chasing so I think there  was a lot of pressure that we put on  ourselves to want to deliver something a  lot like wow and another wow and it led  us down strange paths  you